we take the position in our hospitals
very very seriously of course we do
but if you look at the figures yesterday
uh we had
about 80 percent of our intensive care
capacity occupied and that is not
unusual for this uh time of year but
we're not we're not in any way
complacent we have always put health
first
uh this year and we'll continue uh to do
that but health is about more than
controlling the virus k
if we go into a lockdown where we don't
support
people who are in the lowest paid
professions we'll have a mental health
crisis on top of a pandemic and
that's the point that i've been making
in standing up for those people
um why do you feel that westminster
doesn't
best understand the needs of the north
because when i put it to the minister he
said basically they're trying to save
lives
well so were we um and we've been
working with them all year to do that
and i'm very proud of the council
leaders here and everything
that our nhs has done we've worked
really really hard to do that but as i
said before
uh life is about more than the virus and
i think westminster sometimes struggles
to understand that people can't pay
two-thirds of their rent or um uh two
thirds of their bills you know
it's easier if you're on a a middle
income salary
um you can cope with living on two
thirds of it for a while but it's not
possible to do that if you're the lowest
paid and that let's just be really clear
about this okay
tier three lockdowns affect the lowest
paid people in society
people who work in pubs people who drive
taxis people who work on the doors in
pubs
these are the people that westminster
politicians traditionally
ignore but we are not going to do that
here if you're going to impose a
lockdown here
it's going to cause certain harm certain
harm to all of the people that i've i've
mentioned and that is why
we we have have stood firm because we
don't believe we can consign our
residents
uh to to hardship in that way what
exactly has the government
offered you or what another another way
of putting it what more do you want from
the government
well we got a letter last night um which
was a bit provocative in that it was a
late night ultimatum but i'm gonna try
and be positive this morning and look at
look at the
parts of the letter that you know give
me some grounds for hope and there was a
reference in the letter
to potential additional support so we've
never had a figure for that
what that might mean so it's a bit odd
to be given an ultimatum
we don't think we've concluded those
those discussions but i'm going to
consult the great manchester leaders
this morning
and i i would propose to those leaders
that we write to the government this
morning
setting out what we think is a fair
figure given kay
that we here have been under
restrictions for three months already
tier two restrictions i hear voices in
london calling for support because
they're in tier two now
well i don't disagree with them but bear
in mind we've been in those restrictions
since july that's the first point
but the the second point is we need full
flexibility
over that funding so we can support the
people who we believe will need to be
supported
through everything a tier three lockdown
will mean
okay what figure are you looking at
well you know it's not right is it to go
into those negotiations
those are for the discussions with the
government and you know we're trying to
do this in the right way we're trying
not to
burn i'm sorry i suppose mr mayor that
people will be saying how come you're
only having these last minute
negotiations now why didn't you give him
a figure
to start with that you wanted of course
we've been sharing those those figures k
and those often are
the subject negotiations but i've always
said it's not about the size of the
check
the question is will we have enough to
help the people who will be most harmed
by this will we be able to help the
businesses
that are now close to collapse because
of three months of restrictions there
are many businesses in hospitality
in greater manchester that literally now
are on the brink
and the question is you know will we be
able to help those businesses
to survive so that that's the discussion
that we've been having
with the government and and we will
continue to have and as i say
we will respond in a positive way to
this uh to this letter we will
continue to seek an agreement but an
agreement
which protects people businesses and
communities
from the harm that a tier three lockdown
will cause um
what would you do if i mean you've put
your neck on the line on this one mr
mayor what would he do if restrictions
are imposed
well of course we wouldn't break the law
um we've never said that we
that we would um we would obviously
um have to uh accept that decision in
the end it's the government's
prerogative
but i i would say to them at this point
uh are they sure that that is a wise
thing to do because this isn't just
greater manchester's
uh problem is it because everywhere
could end up in
tier three over over the winter and if
they impose tier three on places without
providing that that support you know put
a punishing lock down on places during
the winter
it will be the the poorest people that
will that will suffer the most as a
result of that
uh okay and i would say to them that the
government will be
at risk of losing what public support
remains for the approach
that they're that they're taking and the
other thing i would just add here is
all of the experts chief medical officer
chief scientific advisor the deputy
chief medical officers every single one
of them
has said to us that they are not certain
tier three will work
and the only way it's got a chance of
working is if you
fully fund it so that lots of things can
close
so that they can have the maximum impact
but the problem with the government
strategy is it isn't doing that it's
trying to
to peddy pinch on tier three and that's
the problem
i don't think its own strategy will work
it's not backing itself to make its
strategy
work and i think people need to think
seriously about that
so it is about the size of the check
then
sorry it is about the size of the check
then
it's about the right level of support
for people
uh for people to survive for businesses
uh to survive
and the flexibility for us to be able to
to help uh people
uh through this uh so you know that
question implies that this is all about
us you're trying to get money for
councils or for our budgets
it's not about that this is about people
and we are doing our best to protect
them in very difficult
circumstances as i say of course we take
controlling the virus extremely
seriously
but we also take people's welfare very
seriously particularly
the welfare of people who have leased uh
and
that is what this is about it's what
it's always been about and can i just
remind all of your viewers this morning
kay that this isn't just
me or this isn't just labour politicians
here this unites us
all across the political spectrum in
greater manchester
so you know i would just ask the
government to remember that
their own council leader their own mps
uh believe that greater manchester needs
a better
uh a better deal than the one that is is
being offered
you said in an interview the other day i
think uh mr mayor that
you believe the problem with these
negotiations was the chancellor
is that still the case
well i think something has changed
hasn't it so earlier in the year it was
you know the wartime chancellor whatever
it takes we will help you all through
this and
you couldn't fail to be impressed by
that i was impressed uh by that it was
the right thing
to do we're in a crisis and people need
support in a crisis
but it does appear there's been an
abrupt change
since the summer where it's the opposite
now
um we're trying to to respond to a
pandemic on the cheap that's how it how
it feels
and it's particularly relevant isn't it
when you then come to a regional
lockdown because
by definition these are going to be um
divisive and if you don't fully fund
them you are going to widen
um the divides in in society the danger
for me
of a an underfunded regional lockdown is
that it becomes
uh an act of leveling down from a
government which said it would do
the opposite okay um so just to be clear
just before i let you go i know that
you've got a busy day ahead what happens
between now
and midday are you expecting to have a
chat with the prime minister on the
phone
you're going to be speaking to your
colleagues high noon comes then what
happens
certainly speaking to my colleagues okay
that's the first thing that i will be
doing
and let me just say again i want to
stress this i will respond as
constructively
and as positively as i can to the letter
that's been sent it does talk of
additional support so let's talk about
that
but it must come with that flexibility
to help people as i've been describing
throughout this interview people who are
self-employed people whose businesses
are
you know almost almost gone so
that's the that's the issue but it will
be a constructive response
we will probably write to the government
at some point this morning
setting out what we think is a fair
resolution
of this issue the prime minister wants
to ring me of course i would always
i would always speak to him you know
people will have to judge this situation
won't they as to
how it's been handled but i am
absolutely
certain in my mind that we have done the
right thing
it is no right thing to put your area
into a into a lockdown when you've
already been in three months
of restrictions that is not a light
thing to do you have to think
really carefully before you do it you
have to consider
the impact on the lowest paid within our
within our communities
and that is why we've taken the position
that we have and
i i am absolutely confident that we've
done the right thing
and if you do enter tier three will you
consider your position
well i would always i always consider
what i've done and whether it was the
the right thing to have done but i think
i've just said to you
at no point do i think i've i've acted
in the wrong way here people say
posturing well
it isn't posturing to represent the
people who have least in society that in
my view is what politics
should be about and actually what
politics has kind of forgotten about
in in recent times who in western speaks
up for people driving taxis
who down there speaks up for people
working in pubs or in bookies they they
don't
largely so politics is in the end of the
day about representation
giving people a voice and i believe i've
done that
uh it's up to other people here to judge
whether i've done the right thing or the
wrong thing
but uh i am as i say in my own mind uh
i i feel i've done what what i should do
in the role that i hold